nothing lasts forever especially when
Hollywood is concerned whether they're
classic comedies or action-packed
spectacles these iconic film franchises
have been left behind by the studios
that created them
The Mummy Series has a long history of
remakes and reboots the Brendan Fraser
and Rachel Vice incarnation of the film
that most film goers are familiar with
is actually just one in a long line of
adaptations of the same story that's why
it shouldn't have come as a huge
surprise when Universal Pictures
released a new take on the franchise in
the form of 2017's the Mummy starring
Tom Cruise as U.S soldier Nick Morton
the film follows Morton after he
inadvertently resurrects an ancient
Egyptian princess who was mummified
alive estimates suggest that the mummy
lost Universal Pictures tens of millions
of dollars as reviewers lambasted the
film that wasn't all the failure of the
film had even larger consequences
effectively canceling an entire
franchise before it had even managed to
properly establish itself the Dark
Universe was Universal's answer to the
MCU and interconnected cinematic series
built around classic horror films a now
anthemous Twitter post teased projects
starring Russell Crowe Johnny Depp and
Javier Bardem but none of them ever came
to fruition
my name is Jekyll
Dr Henry Jekyll
just a few months after the release of
the Mummy the studio postponed one of
the projects before the franchise was
scrapped entirely
like many other movie franchises
Divergent is adapted from a series of
young adult novels the action of this
series mainly takes place in a dystopian
version of Chicago where humans are
strictly divided into one of five groups
depending on what their dominant virtue
is protagonist Tris Pryor played by
Charlene Woodley joins the faction that
values courage and discovers a Sinister
conspiracy at the heart of this
post-apocalyptic Society the first film
in the collection hit Cinema screens in
2014 grossing more than 288 million
dollars against a budget of 85 million
that success was enough to lead to two
sequels arriving over the next two years
despite a rather mixed reception from
critics and fans while the first movie
was helmed by Neil Berger who had proven
himself a capable director with
Limitless years earlier Robert schwinke
the man responsible for the box office
bomb rapd took on the job for the
sequels the follow-ups were met with
criticism and failed to meet Financial
expectation alongside significantly
increased budgets plans for the second
entry in the two-part finale to conclude
the story were ultimately shelved while
a possible television spin-off was also
canceled this was most likely a result
of the original actors turning down the
chance to continue playing their
characters in a smaller budget setting
based on Rick Riordan's young adult
novel series of the same name the Percy
Jackson film series started out in 2010
with the release of Percy Jackson and
the Olympians the Lightning Thief this
first installment was directed by Chris
Columbus the legendary director behind
everything from home alone and Mrs
Doubtfire to Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone with such an esteemed
Name Behind the project there was hope
that it would lead to an entire
franchise the Percy Jackson series takes
place in modern times where ancient
Greek gods live alongside humans Percy
Jackson is the demigod son of Poseidon
and he embarks on a mission to rescue
his mother and return Zeus's lightning
bolt to prevent an all-out war between
the deities the second entry in the
series Percy Jackson Sea of Monsters
arrived three years later in 2013 and
sees Percy attempt to reclaim the Lost
golden fleets fans critics and even
original author Reardon all chastised
the filmmakers for deviating
significantly from The Source material
this this may have been part of the
reason why films failed to find much
success at the box office and why there
have been no attempts to add any extra
installments to this movie franchise the
gods are angry however a new live-action
TV series for Disney plus is in the
works with Reardon working closely on
the production to ensure it follows the
books
written and directed by Wolfgang
Peterson with Hermann Weigel also
contributing to the screenplay 1984 is
the never-ending story is an adaptation
of German author Michael Indy's novel of
the same name the tale follows a young
boy called Bastian who finds himself
absorbed in a magical book the mystical
land at the center of the story Fantasia
is being threatened by a mysterious and
seemingly malevolent Force known only as
the nothing the never-ending story was
not a huge financial success but it did
draw plaudits from critics for its
imaginative narrative and striking
visuals the first film is now well
remembered but its subsequent sequels
are usually not held in the same regard
the never-ending Story 2 the next
chapter failed to make back its budget
while the never-ending Story 3 told a
completely original tale but it did use
familiar characters from the previous
films and the original novel despite its
title the never-ending story did indeed
end after three installments the series
has remained dormant ever since and
there is little evidence that it will be
returning to the screen Green in the
near future
parody films have been a part of the
Hollywood Machine for a long time from
airplane to Galaxy Quest and Shawn of
the Dead some of the most successful
comedies of all time have been parodies
these scary movie franchise is one of
the more memorable parody series out
there with five installments released
from 2000 to 2013 created by the Wayans
brothers the movies typically poke fun
at tropes within horror films lampooning
properties such as scream and the ring
[Applause]
none of the entries in the scary movie
series have been critical Darlings but
the first movie proved to be a huge box
office hit it made more than 270 million
dollars against a budget of just 19
million but subsequent films have faced
dwindling success part of the reason the
series has remained dormant since Scary
Movie 5 could well be because of a
dispute between the Wayans brothers and
Studio Dimension films the brothers have
previously spoken about how they felt
the franchise was stolen from them and
exploited with too many films
the Highlander franchise is arguably one
of the most bizarre movie series in
history through five live-action films
of questionable quality along with
numerous television series and animated
projects the series continued from the
1980s all the way up to 2007. the first
entry simply titled Highlander saw
Christopher Lambert take on the role of
Conor MacLeod an immortal being trapped
in an endless battle with other
Immortals attempting to take each
other's Powers mentored by Juan Sanchez
Villalobos Ramirez played by Sean
Connery he attempts to stop the evil
figure known as the kurgan from claiming
the coveted prize subsequent films some
of which have essentially been retconned
by Future installments follow MacLeod
and Ramirez and tell of their Origins as
well as future Adventures while none of
the films have been major box office
successes the original Highlander has
developed a cult following spawning
everything from comics and novels to
video games however the movie series is
languished for some time and it seems
filmmakers are no closer to Bringing
McLeod back to the big screen
after appearing in a handful of radio
and TV commercials Jim Barney's Goofy
character Ernest P Worrell made the jump
to feature film in 1987. starting with
Ernest Goes to Camp Ernest went on a
number of exciting Adventures nine to be
exact Earnest is a fast talking and
seemingly invulnerable figure who loves
disguises and he gets into various
mishaps including a stint behind bars
and a return to school despite his
movies largely failing to resonate with
critics they were commercially
successful thanks to their low budgets
the final Earnest film Earnest in the
Army released directly to video in 1998.
several other entries in the franchise
were shelved before filming began and
Varney passed away in 2000 before any of
the projects could be made a possible
reboot of the series was explored in
2012 under the title son of earnest but
it never came to fruition there's been
no word about any potential further
films since then and it's hard to
imagine that any living actor would be
able to do the iconic character Justice
what we've got here is failure to
accumulate
officially titled Homeward Bound the
Incredible Journey this 1993 Adventure
film follows a band of two dogs and a
cat who find themselves journeying
Across America when they're forgotten in
a move thanks to a miscommunication it's
essentially a remake of the 1963 film
The Incredible Journey which features a
similar group of animals and was based
on an even earlier novel by Sheila
bernford receiving widespread Acclaim
for both critics and audiences Homeward
Bound was successful enough to Warrant a
sequel the second film was released in
1996 under the name Homeward Bound 2
lost in San Francisco and it sees the
same animals traveling through the
California streets after their family
takes a vacation abroad however it
didn't quite capture the same magic as
his predecessor and following the
release of the sequel which once again
starred Michael J fox and Sally Field
there have been no other Homeward Bound
movies
the Dirty Harry film series first began
in 1971 charting the story of Clint
Eastwood's Perry Callahan as the
attempts to track down a serial killer
known as Scorpio this no-nonsense cop
isn't afraid to use his violent
tendencies in some unorthodox methods to
take down the man terrorizing San
Francisco and bring Justice back to the
streets what I'm saying is that man had
rights
well I'm all broken up about that man's
rights Eastwood's performance and the
popularity of Callahan as a character
quickly led to further releases magnum
force was the first Dirty Harry sequel
in 1973 which was Then followed up by
the enforcer in 1976 and Sudden Impact
in 1983. the final appearance of the
detective came in 1988 in a film called
The Dead Pool bringing the Dirty Harry
series to a close despite the fact that
the franchise established a new
archetype for Relentless detectives who
were willing to work outside the law the
series has never been revived
the first film and what has become known
as the Billy Jack film series arrived in
1967 in the form of the born losers this
was followed by the 1971 movie Billy
Jack and later the trial of Billy Jack
and Billy Jack goes to Washington
portrayed by Tom Laughlin Billy Jack is
a heroic half Navajo Green Beret who
protects a community of outcasts and
underrepresented students Jack does
everything he can not just to help those
in need but to safeguard the week as the
series progresses Billy Jack touches on
everything from Native American rights
to the effects of the Vietnam War Jack
eventually stands trial for his actions
and even enters Politics as a senator to
continue his mission of fighting for
those that others have forgotten the
final installment was released in 1977
and plans for a Revival in 1985 called
The Return of Billy Jack were ultimately
canceled after Laughlin suffered a
serious head injury and production funds
ran out
one of the earliest film franchises in
Hollywood the Thin Man was a comedy
mystery series featuring two
protagonists from dashiel hamit's 1934
novel of the same name husband and wife
Duo Nick and Nora Charles find
themselves playing detective in various
films and the quick-witted sophisticated
and occasionally argumentative pairing
became something of a Trope in detective
stories spawning a host of copycats
played by William Powell and Myrna Loy
in all six films between 1934 and 1947
the sleuths would use their
understanding of glamorous Lifestyles
and instincts for spotting hidden Clues
to solve cases the movies featuring the
pair are widely seen as Classics and the
influence of the Thin Man Series has
been important to the detective genre
unfortunately very few modern film fans
are aware of who these characters are or
the films that they were a part of as
the franchise has been left abandoned
except for a brief time when Johnny Depp
was expected to lead a Revival
hello
foreign